millions of Americans are under a winter storm
watch as the first of back-to-back storms is
expected to hit the Northeast this weekend the
storm system could bring heavy snow freezing
rain ice and Gusty winds Sunday into Monday the
storm will also mean more snow for Maine just days
after a system from the Rockies pushed East and
dumped half a feet of snow in most parts of the
state meteorologist Kelly cast from our partners
at the weather channel has the very latest Kelly
good morning good morning our very active weather
pattern continues from coast to coast we've got a
system now that's affecting us across the Southern
and Central Plains bringing several inches of snow
to parts of Kansas back into New Mexico as well
and eventually bringing quite a bit of snow for
the interior sections of the Northeast not
so much for the coastline though where we're
still waiting on that first measurable snow this
season we haven't gone yet in New York City or
Philadelphia we're going to be on the Rainy side
and plenty of rain across the southeast as well
here's the way it plays out for today of course
the blue that is your snow it's heading for the
plaza in Kansas City as we go toward the afternoon
overnight tonight into early tomorrow morning it
heads for Chicago where we could see anywhere from
a trace to a couple of inches of snow Indianapolis
we've got you in the blue which means snow but
that rain snow line pretty far to the North to
the South there will be some showers possibly
some strong thunderstorms in south Georgia as
well as Southern Cal South Carolina and then that
system really gets going here along the coastline
producing some very strong winds but the snow is
mainly for the interior not really bothering us
along the 95 Corridor except for maybe Maine and
Boston kind of getting sideswiped by a little bit
of snow on its way out now the next system is
bigger it's going to be basically bringing a
lot more snow to the South look at Texas Oklahoma
and Arkansas the European and the American models
want to give some pretty heavy snow there as well
as portions of New England and you can watch the
Weather Channel on cable or live on your favorite
TV streaming devices Michelle Kelly thank you